the jogan experience you know we were
talking today earlier while we're at the
range about Instagram and about the [__]
you see on Instagram these days and we
were talking about how when we were kids
faces of death was the wildest thing
we'd ever seen like and it was nothing
compared to what you see on Instagram
nothing nothing you can go on Instagram
and see 1150 I'm about you know I'm
about to get on my so box right yeah
please you can go on Instagram and watch
1150 million people get stabbed shot
killed off buildings and it'll show up
on your Explorer page right I post a
picture of a
gun I'm throttled I don't show up on
explore page a gun on my explore page
it's
they the level of it's not even I don't
even call it Shadow Banning anymore they
tell you they're doing it MH like I
can't post I even not post against this
is the responsible way to handle a
firearm throttled yeah know throttled
like it's insane on in like what what
Instagram is doing to the Community is
monumentally insane so you know what the
[__] up part about it is because of
the way they are about that the only
representation of firearms that you're
going to get exposed to generally
speaking if you're not already following
them are the negative representations of
firearms or the unsafe way to handle a
firearm because those are making it but
the [__] that we post post the
responsible [__] that doesn't bro how
many videos have you seen of dudes in
like traditional Arab attire shooting
the guns off there and then then they
accidentally shoot their friend there's
so many of those you see way more of
those
dancing dot dot dot dot dot bang dude
gets it in the head you want to know how
I I've seen so many of those you want to
know how I learn gun safety when I got
in the guns sure [__] YouTube because
there were so many examples of people
when I started when I got into guns and
I got into gun Community there were so
many people who reiterating over and
over and over again check your gun make
sure it's clear never pointed at
something you're not willing to destroy
guns are are always loaded at all times
no matter what it it became ingrained in
my brain like they almost shamed you
into gun safety well one of the things
today was a very good representation of
that everyone today had responsible gun
safety habits everyone today everyone
was pointing the gun at the ground
everyone's clearing the gun no one ever
pointed a gun at the direction of
someone people were constantly checking
even after they cleared the gun they
were literally probably 25 guns M out
there yeah and magazines all over the
place all over the place but like I said
but that's it's it's establishing that
safety Dynamic yes and you can't and
they talk about man I'm getting on my
soap boox get on they talk about the
other side talks about this idea of gun
safety firearm safety and the way they
go about doing it is by blocking off all
the people who are teaching the safe way
to handle a firearm I don't understand
this if you want to have a population we
have 400 million guns in this country
the guns aren't going anywhere so if you
want to minimize the number of kids who
accidentally shoot themselves if you
want to minimize the number of adults
who handle Firearms incorrectly end up
accidentally shooting someone what you
need to do is allow the information of
how to safely handle a firearm be spread
to the public so that they understand it
it works because that's how I learned it
no one came to me and said this is the
safe way to do it I went online I was
learning about firearms and I learned
from the people who are handling them
responsibly how to responsi handle a
firearm and as a result I could I
started creating videos and I started
teaching people how to responsibly
handle firearms and then those people
who start making their own videos and
teaching people how to responsibly
handle Firearms but instead what we're
getting with the dynamic of social media
nowadays is they are trying to shut down
all the people who are demonstrating how
to handle firearm responsibly or even
just talking about the law aspect of it
so do you want people running around out
there who don't understand the legal
aspect of owning a firearm or how when
you actually decide to carry a fire them
when is a good time not to shoot when is
a good time to shoot no instead they
Shadow ban and block all of our
content and only leave the negative
representation out there and then wonder
why all of these accidental shootings
continue to
happen and the negative ones find their
way into my feed all the time from
people that I don't follow exactly so
they must know what they like there's a
we were talking about today about that
thing that you click on that says do you
still want to watch this this could be
disturb so they know they know about it
they know I watched the guy get cut in
half by a train
today they're [__] around on the
train station the guy pushes his friend
and the train comes and his friend goes
in between the train and the crack and
gets ripped apart the guys grab his arms
they pull him and his just guts out of a
torso and everyone's screaming it's
horrible and it just showed up on my yep
I see it all the time so if they have
that warning they must know what that is
does does Tik Tok I don't not on Tik Tok
they banned me but does they banned you
just for showing guns wow just for
showing guns does Tik Tok show violence
do they have that kind of violence I
don't know honestly because you're
bad cuz I was and the the the [__] up
thing about it is is
this like when I started the Tik Tok
page and you remember Tik Tok is younger
audience so what's it skew towards to
teens teens yeah so but the thing about
it is is I can go on Tik Tok and and
watch girls engaged in sex in in in
suggestive suggestive sexual behavior
all day long on Tik Tok
right right and I'm like but
anything with a firearm regardless
whether it's safe or
not they Manan they just banned me just
flat out and I'm like what did I do
exactly here is there any is that anyone
on Tik Tok that shows Firearms or is it
everyone gets banned I'm assuming so I
don't know because I I can't really I
can't scoll I can't peruse it and figure
out what else is on there because even
when I try to I try I try to um uh Whata
call it uh I tried to appeal this
decision and then they just reaffirmed
it and so it's it's one of those things
it's very
frustrating